soit bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes ici pour
un livre que vous avez écrit avec marie
thérèse kuni et qui publiait chez oh
éditions c'est numéro un des ventes en
ce moment tout le monde en parle et
c'est pour ça que vous êtes à tout le
monde en parle
[Musique]
alors soin de vous est masquée parce que
vous portez encore les séquelles du
drame dont vous avez été la victime et
parce que même si le drame qui vous a
frappé ses produits il y a une vingtaine
d'années vous vous cachez toujours
quelque part en europe parce que vous
avez peur d'être retrouvé par les gens
qui ont essayé de vous tuer et
d'ailleurs on peut dire qu'il ya une
femme dans votre cas qui a été assassiné
en italie vingt ans plus tard donc votre
situation ici ce soir et d' assez
périlleuse alors que s'est il passé on
va prendre les choses par le
commencement si vous voulez bien votre
vie donc commence à la fin des années 50
dans un petit village de cisjordanie on
espère un jour là la palestine
indépendante
votre père est paysan il est pas il
n'est pas très riche mais il a dû bien
il a des figures des citronniers il ya
des oliviers il a des moutons ils
avaient chèvre il a six filles il a un
garçon voilà et donc votre frère lui il
a le droit d'aller à l'école alors que
les files n'y vont pas oui mon frère et
l'été le val à l'école et rentrer sort
elle avait les droits des faire qu'est
ce qu'il veut mais pas nous les femmes
on n'avait pas le droit de sortir de la
porte seul ouais alors vous n'apprenez
soit denis à lire ni à écrire seulement
à obéir à votre père à prier dieu et à
détester les juifs tout cas c'est bien
dès votre plus jeune âge on vous apprend
votre père dit les juifs sont des
cochons et vous êtes obligé de ne pas
les aimer c'est le moi ya pas longtemps
j'ai commencé c'est grâce à marie
thérèse il m'a dit tu sais les juifs et
ça c'est les gens comme toi comme moi tu
dois les aimer peu le dieu que je suis
passé devant un boucherie juive et je
vais acheter la viande et je trouve
c'était la première fois j'ai trouvé la
viande elle est excellente comme
d'autres chantiers cher voilà
alors vous ne sortez jamais de chez vous
donc soit quand vous êtes enfant quand
vous sortez vous vous marcher vite la
tête baissée en évitant le regard des
hommes on n'a pas les droits des gardés
ni à gauche ni à droite sinon la plr mgr
moutel ça veut dire
le prostitué
les mots mais ça avec moi c'est ça ne
marche tout droit toujours on sort
toujours avec la plus grande des la
famille un jour
alors vous commencé à travailler à l'âge
de 8 ans vous êtes pieds nus à vous
garder des moutons vous aller traire des
déchets vous faites la cuisine vous
faites le ménage et quand ça va pas
quand il ya un problème par exemple
quand les moutons rentre tout seul votre
père vous bas mais bien sûr elle aurait
pour commencer ma mère elle est mariée à
14 ans apparaît le navet 38 et puis on
avait les moutons à chaque fois où on
faisait une petite faute ça se fait une
fois j'ai brûlé les fourneaux par erreur
malheureusement mais mon père est là ça
y est carrément métaux fait est fait et
nous attacher powell a passé la nuit
avec les moutons avec les vaches meurent
aussi avec nous votre père vous donner
des coups de ceinture aussi comme ça
n'avait pas non plus été tapé mais comme
c'est pas permis une femme la base rien
des tours je parle de ma famille je
parle de mon village je sais pas qu'est
ce qui se passe ailleurs mais une femme
ici un chien vous la ramenez chez le
vétérinaire on voulait premier et pour
prendre l'air et hommes et les femmes
là-bas elle est soumise et les plus qui
sont mises alors vous assistez soit des
scènes extrêmement violente un soir
votre père manque d' étouffer votre mère
parce que il pense que peut-être elle
l'a trompée voyez des scènes terribles
aussi vous voyez votre mère clic étouffe
les filles à la naissance avec une
couverture c'est-à-dire qu'on fait quand
c'est un garçon qui n'est bon le laisse
vivre mais quand c'est une fille a de
fortes chances qu'elles soient tués à la
naissance c'est moins des pivoines a4 a5
si si ça va mais dès que ça passe un peu
plus là c'est la mort vous avez vu ça
avec une avec les deux voitures j'avais
vu ça avec mon propre rire avec une
couverture wi une couverture le montant
de la laine les laine de mouton pardon
alors votre frère lui évidemment c'est
le shérif à lui tout tout tout lui est
permis c'est assad et un jour où le
voyait en train d'étrangler en face à
vous est revenue très tard d'ailleurs
parce que sur moment vous avez voulu
oublier la scène et c'est quelque chose
qui vous est revenue beaucoup plus tard
voyez votre frère étranglé votre soeur
annan avec le fils du téléphone
téléphone oui et là des cours parce
qu'il était au téléphone
les téléphones il sait pas avec qui il
était au téléphone il n'avait pas le
droit d'être téléphone et de la
tramblais oui alors vous ne voyez jamais
la police à une femme qui disparaît
c'est pas un problème c'est pas un
problème déjà l'insee
tu parles de toujours ma famille ont
connu pas d'âge à son corps on sais pas
qu'est ce que c'est que la police ne
sais pas qu'est ce que c'est confieront
ne sais pas vous êtes des noms m en fait
d'une certaine façon oui c'est ça la
seule façon de s'en sortir c'est le sait
le mariage parce que quand on est marié
bon on peut regarder devant soi encore
et encore et encore et encore c'est
l'émotion de ma soeur et laisse mes plus
grandes mais les somistes par mon père
elle était soumise par mon père mais
maintenant elle est soumise par son mari
ah oui et encore c'est rip pas toujours
oui alors celles qui tombent sur des
types plus sympa disons qu'elles ont
droit de regard des 2 devant elle de
faire des courses de porter des bijoux
de s'épiler enfin des choses de ce
métier on met des choses de filles oui
voilà oui normalement on n'a pas les
droits d d d aller chez l'esthéticienne
ou ses plaies c'est mal à l'usure des
mariages le problème pour vous marier
parce que vous avez vraiment envie de
vous marier c'est qu'il vous faut
attendre que votre soeur aînée kahina
soit soit mariée et elle est toujours
pas mariée non parce qu'ils étaient la
pauvre et l'abbé le cas c'est assez
forte et elle n'était pas demandée au
mariage témoin j'étais plus jeune
j'étais demandes de l'ama elle n'avait
pas les droits et j'avais pas les droits
de rang mais marié voilà c'est ma soeur
elle n'était pas mariée voilà donc temps
que votre chien n'est pas marié vous ne
pouvez pas vous marier et là évidemment
un jour vous vous craquez vous tomber
amoureuse d'un dénommé fayez lui les pas
paysan lui il travaille en ville y
travaille dans un bureau un oui très
élégante rien on était très très
amoureux ouais il avait une voiture il
avait une voiture un peu cette moisins
une voiture à quatre places et moi tu
leur as ta place oui j'ai encore la
mémoire les bonnes et alors vous essayé
de l'attirer ce fayez vous mettez votre
pull over rouge votre votre plus beau
pull over pour kiel pour qu'il vous
regarde et lui
à bord d'un jour et commencé à parler
avec vous et il dit qu'il a discuté avec
votre votre père et moi j'ai vu ton père
il ya pas de problème on va se marier
t'en fais pas tu peux venir avec moi il
n'y a pas de souci il vous a raconté ça
à leur premier baiser évidemment ensuite
vous faites l'amour pour la première
fois et puis vous vous retrouver
enceinte et je me suis trop bien simple
oui mais je suis donné rendez-vous avec
mon ami les pas des nues oui c'est à
dire que au début quand quand vous
tomber enceinte vous vous dites il va
revenir on va se marier cette formidable
espoir donc pendant plusieurs jours vous
vous le mettez vous êtes sur la terrasse
de chez vous mais quand vous regardez
s'il vient mais bien s'il ne vient pas
non il est parvenu parce qu'elle avait
peur je sais pas pour quelle raison
alors la veille à votre ventre qui
commence à grossir vous vous acharnez
sur votre ventre à coups de pierres vous
essayez dès le coup de pierre rouge
allure que des enfants mais je n'ai pris
moi-même les grosses pierres top 10 sur
nos ventes pour faire descendre les
bébés d'asthme amer il est venu vers moi
et m'a dit toi tu es enceinte bien
attendez je rêvais pas les dire oui et
les voyez l'état chébran sur le nez les
tâches et bras sur le baudet ça et puis
il n'est pas descendu malheureusement de
bébé est resté
donc votre ventre grossit de plus en
plus c'est un soir vous entendez hussein
votre beau frère vous proposez à votre
mère de vous tuer c'est moi papa et ma
maman il a proposé métier est carrément
oui j'ai attendait quand j'étais dans la
pièce et puis j'ai demandé à ma ma tante
la soeur de ma maman il va mais protégé
est temps que tu m'aides elle m'a dit
d'accord il m'a donné la main tom hilde
comme je donne enfin un enfant d une
année mais une fois que j'ai rêvé devant
la porte de chez moi j'ai saigné reculé
en arrière elle m'a poussé et puis la
dette je rentre à la maison je savais
que c'était la dernière jour de ma vie
et là vous comprenez soit que vous allez
être victime de ce qu'on appelle un
crime d'honneur vous êtes devenu une
charmante à une charmante en relais pour
la famille pour les villages pour
vous avez déshonoré votre famille et si
vous n'êtes pas tué
les gens du village rejetteront la faute
sur votre famille
alors là bas ce qu'on appelle nous un
crime d'honneur c'est pas un crime pour
eux c'est normal
dit là dedans on aimait et là dedans
lorsqu'il faut dire simplement à nos
amis téléspectateurs c'est que c'est pas
une coutume qui est propre à la religion
musulmane
est aussi appliquée par les chrétiens du
moyen-orient c'est en fait une coutume
tribale préislamique qui date d'avant le
prophète et qui existent aussi dans les
pays comme le bangladesh et le brésil
voilà alors un matin la maison est vite
vos parents sont partis ils sont mes
descentes détecter les villages vous
vous êtes à couper dans la cour en train
de en train de faire la lessive et je
rentre la lessive alors mon papa et
maman maïs on partait peut faire la
lessive t à mon beau-frère et larry des
pulls mais fais tu sais je vais t'aider
je n'ai pas dit quand il vous dit je
vais m'occuper de toi il plaisante un
peu il est sympa et il était très sympa
pu savourer sur j'étais très jeune je
dois bosser gentilles va m'aider et
plutôt qu'est-ce que j'ai sont élevés
mais l'essence sur les cheveux oui vous
sentez un liquide froid malades je
sentais les pics de froid sur la tête et
je sais pas c'est avec une brève à dater
une allumette je sais pas tout puisque
chef j'avais les feux sur ma tête j'ai
commencé à courir dans les jardins en
tapant des mains sur mes cheveux et puis
j'ai sauté les bébés elle bouge à
l'intérieur de mon ventre et pc là les
oiseaux ils ont étalé ce avec l'eau les
préfectures cas vous sauter un petit
muret vous retrouver dans la rue minutes
il ya deux voisines qui vous emmène à la
fontaine et qui essaye on essaye
d'éteindre le fait parce que vous êtes
en faisons mais je tente sa part
complètement machettes et brûlées au
troisième degré vous voulez mourir à ce
moment là et ce moment là je voulais
mourir oui alors vous vous réveillez à
l'hôpital
on vous enlève votre enfant qui était né
miraculeusement dans un état de 2000
conscience et on vous soigne à peine en
fait les médecins s'occupent à tellement
de vous pensez vous avez mourir très
très mal il me prenais par les cheveux
elle même était dans la baignoire pour
me laver mais seulement par les cheveux
elle me soigner très très mal vous êtes
brûlée au troisième degré vous avez eu
le menton la psychose est collé à la
poitrine
sont brûlés oui et alors là votre mère
vient vous voir quand vous voyez arriver
votre mère ce jour-là à l'hôpital vous
pensez qu'elle vient vous aider alors
c'était loin dé là j'ai dessiné les
diamé parler ou bien tu sais pas les
venelles apple avait chez pas vu les
vertes céder la main je ne rêvais pas
tourner la tête mais à gauche la droite
j'étais collé et puis c'est là il m'a
détient che vaut boire ça comme ça à ton
frère il va pas avoir les dangers et
j'étais prête à boire cette sphère
déposant pour pâques mon frère et les
leurs à de mal c'était la seule version
de la famille alors pour nous c'est
quelque chose et pourquoi vous l'avez
pas vu sévère de poison alors c'est
grâce à mon médecin il rentrait au bon
moment c'est le message de bon dieu sept
médecins il est venu et puis la
primevère des poisons j'ai plus vu ma
mère
donc vous restez dans cet hôpital et la
chance pour vous soit s'appelle
jacqueline thibault tout à fait elle
travaille pour la croix-rouge dans le
militaire au moyen-orient oui et elle se
met en tête de vous sauver absents h et
à votre tête a fait les univers mois et
il n'est fait je vais t'aider telma met
la main sur les genoux et je le
regardais j'étais d'accord et grâce à
jacqueline thébaux grâce à une fondation
hamon suis je suis vivante aujourd'hui
mon fils et moi alors à ce moment là
jacqueline va voir vos parents parce que
pour vous sortir du pays il ya besoin
d'une autorisation de de vos parents et
elle va les voir elle leur dit toute
façon puisque elle est condamnée vu
qu'elle va mourir autant qu'elles
aillent mourir ailleurs et grâce à ceux
à ce stratagème finalement elle arrive à
vous arracher à cet hôpital elle vous
emmène d'abord à bethléem et ensuite en
europe elle sauve aussi marouane
votre enfant
25 ans maintenant
vous arrivez en suisse les opérations
commencent vous avez 24 opérations g20
cette opération je restais l'oph mort à
l'hôpital war ou 6 27 opérations l'hydre
f
grâce à cette opération mais 27
opérations mais j'étais très contente
d'inviter bien soigner les gens il était
très gentil avec moi d'acteurs la forme
hier j'étais très contente les blessures
les plus graves sont évidemment à
l'intérieur vous avez beaucoup de mal à
vous reconstruire évidemment suite à ce
drame vous êtes incapables d'élever
votre fils marouane et vous le confier à
une famille d'accueil pour qu'il soit
élevé normalement des eaux ont tout à
fait oui parce que je ne pouvais pas
j'avais pas de la force mais n'est que
peu d'élus et épais la gelée adopté à
cette famille d'accueil et puis en vingt
ans on s'est vu trois fois à un moment
vous rencontrer un autre homme qui
s'appelle antonio
lui veut pas se marier vous voulez vous
marier vous finissez par l'épouser c'est
l'émoi et c'est assez beau vous avez
deux petite fille laëtitia nadia oui
oui avec obtenions mais la dépression
vous guette quand même vous êtes très
complexée par des cicatrices qui couvre
votre corps vous n'osez pas vous mettre
en maillot de bain
mais à manches courtes et un décolleté
né en jupe légère je peux pas la piscine
et ça c'est assez pénible président doit
pas dire 7 janvier est un jour vous
faites soit d'une tentative de suicide
vous n'en pouvez plus oui j'essaye de me
suicider
j'ai dit non je suis pas le droit parce
qu'il ya missiles et sans besoin de moi
oui je voulais me suicider passer un
moment donné c'était très lourd encore
maintenant parfois c'est très très lourd
donc là vous subissez une thérapie pour
vous en sortir une psycho logiquement
dirons nous et vous souffrez toujours
évidemment c'est normal qu'on attende
angoisse terrible faire mieux par
exemple si vous voyez une bougie
ne sera pas le même bouger je peux pas
aller mais j'ai eu l'occasion j'ai
acheté maison je vais les mettre les
plaqueurs au gaz mais je n'ai pas voulu
céder à mon arrêt je vois pas mais
impossible de toucher n'abriter de la
mort ouais ça n'arrive pas mais si nous
plaise ou pas ouais c'est plus fort que
moi je reste alors aujourd'hui bas je
dirais ça a pas mal quoi votre famille
est réunie vous avez retrouvé marouane
qui finalement est venu habiter avec
vous vous avez donc trois enfants vous
avez un métier vous êtes secrétaire du
travail et gagner votre vie et vous
décidez à ce moment-là de témoigner pour
que toutes les victimes des crimes
d'honneur soit reconnu et que les gens
qui commettent ces crimes d'honneur ne
soient plus des héros mais ce qu'ils
sont vraiment des assassins actuellement
j'ai fait ce livre c'est mon but qu'il
va pour sauver les autres parce qu'il ya
encore aujourd'hui et demain wen sans
brûler et tout fait étranglée torturée
la mort n'a pas volu de vous
deux fois de suite
c'est un signe c c'est pour ça que vous
êtes là c'est pour ça je suis là
vous diriez quoi souad à votre mère si
elle était en face de vous la maintenant
vous savez autre fois j'ai haï c'est ma
mère mais finalement maintenant j'ai des
miss n'est pas sa faute parce qu'elle
était soumise par un père elle était
soumise par mon frère l'homme il fait
les rois encore une fois j'aurais déjà
mais les guerres pettinger parle de
l'homme je suis en danger j'essaie
ravagé parce qu'il n'a pas le droit
pourquoi lui il a le droit tout faire
s'habiller s'amuser sortait rentrée mais
pourquoi pas nous les femmes c'est pas
la faute des ma mère bah si mais
actuellement je t en six jours damier je
ferai la même chose que ma mère il l'a
fait à sony mais là dedans c'était à
fait normal alors maintenant je veux
absolument je veux pas dire pardon à ma
mère ça c'est clair mais c'est pas sa
faute non plus c'est pas non plus la
faute de votre père parce que lui aussi
il a été élevé là dedans et je dois dire
c'est la faute de l'homme j'arrête pas
le dire aujourd'hui et demain geste à la
fin de ma vie c'est la faute de l'homme
c'est j'aimerais bien c'est changer
l'homme c'est le méconnu changeait pas
la femme beth la femme l'apport tu
l'aidés tête à ça y est c'est tout bouge
pas pourrait être serrée bouge pas c'est
l'homme mais faut le changer pas la
femme
mais il faut changer changer tout ça bah
vous y participer en étendant je
participe et je suis prête à lait
d'animaux donc tu es témoignait pour
qu'on le change pour sauver les autres
filles
ça s'appelle brûlées vives et séchez vos
éditions mesdames messieurs merci soir
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu